1番目の偈なんですね
マノプッバンガマーダンマー
マノーセッターマノマヤ
マナサーチェパドッテーナ
バーサティーワーカロティワ
タトーナン ドゥッカマンヴェーティ
チャッカンワハトーパダン
という あの それはダンマパダの 1番目の偈なんですね
で マノープッバンガマーダンマも我々は全部ほとんど暗記して
最初の文句だからね ですけど
マノーセッターマノマヤ
マナサーチェパドッテーナ
バーサティワーカロティワ
タトーナン ドゥッカマンヴェーティ
チャッカンワハトーパダン
で それで一節ずつ意味を考えてみます
マノープッバンガマーダンマ
マノーっていうのは心ですね
で プッバンガマーっていうのは
フォーラナーという日本語はどうかわかりませんですけど
まあ先に行動する いわゆる心が優先ということですね
ダンマーっていうのは
この場合は物事 まあ英語で言えばフェノミナということなんですね
それでまあ英訳だったらザマインドイズザフォーラナーフォーラナーオブフェノミナとなりますが
まあまあ一応即答で言えば
何事も心次第ですという意味なんですよ
世の中にあるもう一切の何事でも心次第ですよと
だから心が優先で 心が先で
心が全部決めちゃうということ
はい そこでダンマーって私はこの物事と訳しましたけど
これに怒られる方々もいるかもしれませんね
で 私の解釈間違ってるんだよと
で まあ裏で言ってるんだから
あまり気にする必要はないんですけどね
で ダンマーっていうのは普通日本語だったら法という言葉で訳せますよ
だから意味はいくつかあります
ブッダの教えにもダンマという真理という意味でもダンマという真理っていうのは
まあ本当のこと だから人間の考え方
解釈ではなくて 実際のことは
例えば科学的な事実みたいなもので
どうにもならんという
例えば地球が丸いと言ったら
まあこれはもうどうにもならんことですから
丸いんだからね 宇宙から見れば地球が青いと言えば
もうどうすればいいんですか？青いんですよ
青く見える そのようにこの真理
もう変わらないもの その意味でもダンマーと呼ぶんですね
それから 3番目 実際に存在するもの
それは私たちは知る世界は現象ですね
俗世間が正しいと思っている世界は
世俗体というんです 仏教用語で
で 世俗界を構成するもの
これは生起体といいます
それは法と呼ぶんです
幻想に似ているが 精神的な幻想も入っています
いわゆる幻想論みたいな話なんですね
ダンマといえば実際に存在しているもの
例えば水といっても 水が実際に存在しているわけじゃなくて
あのー 水素と酸素のイオンがもうガチャガチャガチャガチャ回ってるだけなんですね
だからそういうふうに幻想論みたいなもので
でも科学は物質的な幻想しか語ってないんですけど
仏教は精神的な世界も幻想論に分析しているんです
その場合はもう最終的に出会う幻想
心の幻想であろうが 物質的な世界の幻想であろうか
それに法と言うんです
ダンマーというんです
わかりますかね 例えば科学的に言えば
まあ水素があって炭素があったりとかね
それは昔 元素だ それは元やと言っていたんでしょうね
だから元素というでしょうね
で 今になってくると いえ
そうでもない またまたいろいろあるんだよと言ったりする
仏教になってくると 物質世界は地水火風との 4つであって
その 4つが組み合わせると
またいくつか二次的に現れてくるんだよと
それで幻想になる それに法と言うんで
例えば地水火風の地にも法と言うんですね
地法 パタリダン 水法という風に言っちゃうんですね
そこで心 精神的な世界を見ると
例えば怒りっていうのは何か特別な働きをするものなんですね
だからそれは別にそれだけ取って法と言うんですね
怒りという ほんの小さなレベルで
そうやって法と実際に存在するもの
四番目は正しいこと 良いもの
それは倫理的な意味で
あのパーリ語で言えば
まあダンメイナジーレティ法によって生きているんだよと
いわゆる法によってではなくて
法で生きているんだよとという変な訳なんですけど
その場合は法でっていうのは道徳的に悪いことをしないで
良いことだけして生きているんだよっていう意味なんです
そこで政治家に対してブッダがよく使う言葉は
まあダンメイナラジャンカロといういい政府だったら
ダンメイナラジャンカロという法で政権を維持しているんだと
この場合は法でっていうのは法律っていう意味じゃないんです
道徳的で正しいことをして
悪いことをしないで政治をやってますよと
人間に使う場合はダンミコという言葉
そこから名前としても使ってますしね
道徳的なそれから何でしたっけ？それから法則
法則の場合はパーリ語でダンマターというんですね
日本語になってくると法性になるんですよ
それはプリンシパルズという意味なんですね
その場合は何かモノではないんです
法則ですよ 例えばすごい今日寒いんだから
外に出たらもう寒く感じるというふうな
それは法則ですよ どこということではなくて
夏になると暑いだよと
夏になると日が長いんですよと
冬になると日が短いんですよと
それのその法則 それで仏教では因果法則というものがあるんですね
それをダンマと言うんです
それで もし我々出家の人々に向かって
年上の長老で あんたダンマ知ってますか？と聞いちゃうと
実際に聞いているのは
この法則をちゃんと理解しているんですかと
因果法則をお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
で 6番目 ずいぶん軽々とあらゆるもの
もう何にも使う だからすごい難しい言葉なんですよ
もう何にも使う言葉でもあって
元素的な この実際に存在する最小最小の小さなものにも使う
それからブッダの教えにも使う
だからやれやれということで
そのその時 その時で脈絡で意味を取らなくちゃいけない
この学問的に日本訳をするとすごく苦労すると思いますよ
だからわからなくなっちゃいますよ
例えば学者の方々は法ダンマイコール法にしちゃうと
どこでも法という言葉を入れて入れていくんですよ
機械的に でももう合わなくなっちゃうんですよ
この間も質問されてますけど
あの まあサティに気づきやら覚えとかいろいろ言葉ありますけど
一つの言葉でずっと持っていっちゃうと
もうわからなくなるんですよ
だからこのパーリ語っていうのを他の言語に訳すると結構大変ですよ
訳できない言葉というのは
ダンマ ドゥッカ サンカーラ
訳できないドゥッカ 散々使ってるのに
仏教で 空だと言ってますけど
空ではありませんよ だからまあ難しい
はい それでマノーセッターマノーメア
二行目 マノープッバンガマーダンマーマノーセッターマノーメア
マノー心がセッター優れている
例えばダンマーの中である
ダンマーの中にいわゆるあらゆるもの
何でもいいんです 世の中にある
存在の中にあるあらゆるもの
全部 全ての中でマノーセッター
心が偉いということ それでマノーメア
心によって作られている
物事は心が作っているんだろう
この机なんか誰が作ったんですかね
結局心が作ったんですよ
心が考えて 心が計画立てて
心が寸法を測って 心が材料を考えて
それで心が手を動かしちゃって
心が作るんですよ そうするとみんな聞きたくなる
では宇宙は誰が作ったんですか？とかね
だったら神様ではないかとかね
地球は誰が作ったんですか？とかね
で まあそれ使ったって全部心が作ったんだよと
と言えば 宇宙はみんなのものだから
みんなの心が作ったことになります
ある一人の人が作ることになりません
例えばこのお寺は この部屋は
このお寺のもので 一人のものなんです
我々が勝手に使うことはできません
だから まあ一人が作ったなら
その人のそういう仏壇であっても
我々には全然自由がなくなりますけどね
そんなことを見たらないとわかるでしょうしね
だから宇宙に人間 地球にだけ生命がいるわけじゃなくて
もうすごいいろんなところでいろんな生命がいるんだからね
心が作ったと言えば 宇宙全部
全ての生命の心が作ったと思っても構いません
証拠を出せないんだから
我々はあまり言わない
小さい声でも言わない
まあ言っちゃったんですけど
笑 証拠を出すということにいうとね
これ無理ですからね そこで
ブッダは我々に対して何言うかというと
私に対して喋ってるんだから
私の全てのものは私の心が作ってます
私の体も私の心が作ってるんですよ
だから体の形やら健康的か明るいか病弱か
勝手健康的ですけど 突然病気になって
それからずっと病弱には
そういうのはもう心の回転次第ですよ
例えば心が暗くて 暗くて弱いんだったら
食べても栄養が体吸収しない
すごい元気な明るい心だったら
もうろくに食べなくてももうかなり元気とかね
そういう風に心次第ですよ
まあ例えば人々というのは早く老けてしまうでしょう
年よりも それは何なのかというと
そういう人々はすごい神経質で
まあ仕事なんかバリバリやってるかもしれませんだけど
かなりこの緊張して神経質で仕事をすると
もうボンボンアドレナリン出すでしょうね
だからアドレナリン出るか
それは日本語で何て言いますか？ ado
Adrenaline
あ それはそんなできない
とにかく英語の言葉を使います
で アドレナリン アドレナリンというものを作るんですね
それが感情で作るんですよ
心で それが体中を回すとものすごい頑張りますよ
もう眠気なんかさっぱり出てこない
もう何でもできます しかし
それが毒だから それから全部細胞がかなりもう炙った状態になります
そこで我々推薦するのは
リラックスして穏やかな気持ちでやってくださいと
そうすると中途半端になるんじゃないかなと
危険があるんですよ リラックスして
何かニコニコと笑いながら
穏やかな気持ちで中途半端になるんじゃないかなんと
ならないんですよ 集中力っていうのを育てるんだからね
リラックスだけじゃないんだからね
ものに集中する この猿みたいな生活はしません
あっち見たりこっち見たりとかね
やることはしっかりやる
そうすると短い時間でかなりの仕事はできます
ということで 我々は宇宙は誰が作ったと関係ないんですよ
どんな人が作っても もう勝手にしろと
だから私のこの言葉を聞いて
マノーメアは全ては心が作ってるんだよと言ったところで
ちょっと考えすぎて では宇宙は誰が
誰の心から作ったんですか？と考えたら
やりすぎ 思考は 役に立ちません
だから宇宙は誰が作ったっても
もう勝手にしろと その人に
で ここで生きている私にとっては何なのかと
私はどうすればいいかということは
一番具体的なプラクティカルな問題なんですね
神は男か女かとか調べているでしょうね
くだらんことどうでもいいんです
そんなのは で 神に子供見るでしょ
だから男か女かわからないし
男だったら女もいるはずでしょうしね
まあわからないんですけど
そんなのはどうでもいいということを私は言いたいんですよ
私がどうすればいいか
私はどう生きていればいいかということを
私の問題が一番大事なんです
ですから 私の幸福 不幸
健康 不健康 何から何まで心が作っているんです
だから仕事で緊張して
神経質でアドレナリンだけで動いちゃうと
もう結構早くも髪の毛も散るし
もうもう細胞なんかはまあ本当に炙っているような状態なんですよ
だからまあ内臓っていうのは壊れていきます
早く老化します それにリラックスして集中してやる
リラックスしてすると
それはものすごくがっちりするんですよ
集中すると面白くなるんですよ
やりやすくなるんですよ
やりやすくなればなるほどリラックスできるんですよ
なんだ 簡単じゃないかと
面白い 面白いと だからやらなくちゃいかん
やらなくちゃいかんと
という神経質と全く違うんですよ
そういうことで それで次のマナサーチェパドッヘーナ
チェ もしもパドッヘーナ汚れたマナサー心で
次 バーサティワーカロティワー
バーサティ話す カロティというのはするなすこと
ワーっていうのはあるいはということで
オールということで タトーナンドゥッカマンウェーティ
それから苦しみを味わう
味わうんだよと たとえそのことによって
ナン人にドゥッカン苦しみがアンニーティついてくる
ということはどういうことかというと
心が親分で 主体で この心が汚れていると
汚れた心で行動すると
喋ったり話したりすると
その人が苦しみを味わうんだよと
もう離れません 自分の心で汚れた心で行動したんだから
そのもう汚れているんです
もう苦しんでいるんです
だから仏教では審判する人はいないんですよ
他の宗教の友達が昔はすごく私を責めるんで
あなた方は業なんか悪いことしたら悪い結果になるんだよというのはもう私も認めたいんですけど
言ってることはすごくいいんだけど
悪いことしたら誰が罰を与えるんですか？と
それがないとちょっとわからないんだよと
いいことをしたら誰がご褒美してくれるんでしょうか
と私は いえ 別に誰もないんだよ
誰もないと言ったって
それはわかりませんよ
全然理解できませんと言って
まあ若い頃 たくさんいろんな宗教の友達がいたんだからね
私もそんなに口がうまかったわけでもないし
で もうわかってくれないんですね
誰もいないのに 審判する人がね
どうやって悪いことに悪い結果
いいことにいい結果が出るかという
ということはね しかし誰もいません
誰もいません だって 私の心が汚れていると
その汚れた心で行動する
そのまんまもう不幸になってるんだから
ですから 原因そろったらいいということで
例えば私の服が汚れて匂いを出しているとすると
誰が私に嫌な気分匂いを作ってくれるんですかね
誰でもないでしょう もう身についてるんだから
服がですからもう臭いんです
そんな感じで心が汚れたらもう不幸になるんだよと
そういうことで これは厳密な論理で
すごい単純な短い言葉で言うんだけど
ものすごい厳密な論理でものすごい難しいんですよ
それだけでこの支配者
管理者 審判する人 裁判官なしに
人間の生命の生き方を説明しています
はい 次に行きます それで
どのようにこの偈を理解しますかと
広大な意味で理解するものも可能です
例えば全宇宙も心によって創られている
創造されているという解釈
しかし 具体的な証拠を出せません
この場合は 我々個人の生き方と運命
幸不幸ですね 成功 失敗
運の主因は心であると理解する方が良いのです
それがあの偈の意味なんです
意味といったって 私の解釈的な意味なんですね
あのお釈迦様の言葉だけ見ると
ものすごく幅広く解釈することはできるんですけど
やめましょうと なぜならば証拠は出せないんだからね
ですから お釈迦様が言ったのは私個人に対してなんですね
ですから 個人の運命 幸不幸
成功 失敗 あらゆるものの主因
メイン原因は心である
そこでそれをまとめたら
私の支配者は我が心であると
それで覚えておけば いいです
それで命の管理者及び支配者
それもう一つのお釈迦様の言葉なんです
チッテーナニーヤテーローコチッテーナパリカッサティチッタッサーエーカダンマッサーサッベーワワサマンワグー
チッテーナニーヤテーローコ
生命が心に導かれている
いかなるすべての生命を導いているのは心なんですね
チッタ心なんです それで心に引き回されている
私たちは全然自由がないんですよ
仏教も神様がいない そうテーラワーダのこと言ったっても
じゃあでは自由ですか？と
全然自由じゃないんです
なんで自由がないかと
心に引き回されているんですよ
それ心というたった一つのものにすべての生命が支配されている
一切の生命が心というたった一つに支配されています
大体その意味でわかる
次に行きましょう それでまとめた意味は
これ私の趣味なんです
なんとなく変な言葉を作るのは
だから命あるものは心の奴隷であると
で  それで私はまとめる
命あるものはみんな心の奴隷であると
結構自分にとってはかっこいい言葉だと思ってますけど
覚えておけばかなり頭良くなりますよ
試しにそれを覚えておいてください
安全です いつでも口ずさんだりとかね
命あるものは心の奴隷であると
結構頭が冴えてくると思いますよ
私は冗談でふざけて作るんですけど
その裏 かなりの思考というのはあります
だから結局 仏教で言えば誰の奴隷でもないんです
我々は心の奴隷なんですね
心には勝てない 心に振り回されている
はい それでさらに心について
ディソーディサンヤンタンカイラウェリーワーパナウェリナンミッチャーパニータンチッタンパーピョーナンタトーカレ
あのもうちょっと説明して次に行きます
そうするとあのいくらかこれこれで消えますから
この偈はこの幅はこれしかないんだから
たくさん文字は書けません
あの敵が敵に敵同士で
敵が敵同士で敵にすること
心が間違っちゃうと心が間違った方向へ育てると
これぐらいひどいこと自分にするんだ
という意味なんです だからすごい敵同士がいるとしましょう
2人がものすごい互いに敵で憎しみ合っている
そこで隙が見たらなんとかひどいことをする
殺したりもするかもしれません
お釈迦様が言うのは この自分の心が方向を間違うと
自分にどんなことをしますよ
だから実際になぜ人が地獄に落ちるんですかと
皆様 私もあまり言えませんだけど
日本で人気あったアジビ地獄とかね
なんかすごい恐ろしい地獄だと
で まあアジビ地獄よりも恐ろしい地獄はありますけど
なんで人がアジビ地獄に落ちるんですか？とかね
やっぱり心ですよ 心が間違うと人殺しもするでしょう
大量殺人もするでしょう
それでいいわけじゃないんですよ
だからもうものすごい怖いんですよ
心っていうのは その意味で
それから言葉切って定義します
はい 次 ディソーディサンヤンタイカイラっていう偈は
ディソーっていうのは敵がディサン敵にヤン何をカイラするであろうという言葉一つ一つの意味なんですね
それから右側 ウェーリワーパナウェーリナン
あのウェーリっていうのは何でしたかね
怨敵ですか 怨敵がパナっていうのは
またはウェーリナン怨敵に
まあ同じ意味ですよ 敵と言っても
まあパーリ語でもディソーと言ったって
ウェーリと言ったっても
まあニュアンスがちょっと違いますけど
まあ敵が敵にするって意味なんですね
それで左側の下 2番目
ミッチャーパニヒタンチッタン
ミッチャーっていうのは邪悪に間違って
パニヒタン まあ洗練することですね
育てることですね 心が邪悪に育てる
変な方向へ育てる チッタン心
それでたとそれよりもひどいパーアピオ悪人にナンカレーをするであろうと
全然わからない まあとにかく拾ってみれば文章になります
言葉を拾ってあっちこっち移転させると意味があります
まとめて言えば 敵が敵にするように
怨敵が怨敵にするように
するようにではなくて
何をするんでしょうかね
怨敵が怨敵に対して それでわしは推測しますよ
しますよ まあなんかするでしょうと
それよりひどいことをするんだよと
我が心が私に 怨敵が怨敵にするよりもひどいこと
我が心は私にしちゃうんだよと
どんな場合ですかというと
邪悪に育てるとそうなっちゃいますよ
ということで 心ってとても危険なもの
だからこの意訳なんですけど
親仁の人が同じ親仁を持ってる相手に
また怨敵が同じ怨敵を持っている相手に対して行う不幸よりもひどい悪いことを
邪悪に洗練された己の心が自分に対してするのですということ
これはブッダの言葉だからダンマになりますよ
ブッダが真理を語るんだから
事実を語るんだから 真理にもなります
これは違うと言えません
はい 次 それはもうまとめます
今の偈の意味は 自分の心の中に悪魔を大事に育てるのですということで
普通は我々は悪魔を心の中に大事に育てているんですね
あの まあ私はくだらない例え出してますけどね
洋服箪笥にネズミが住み着いているのでは？と
そうすると洋服守られますかね
あるいは泥棒が我が家に住んでいるなら
ならば鍵は何枚かけるのですか？あれは同じ状態
私はちょっとまあなんかふざけて言ってるだけ
泥棒が自分の家にいるんだったら
もう鍵をたくさんかけて
セキュリティもセコムにも頼んでおいたってもね
盗まれますよ 家に住んでるんだから
いくらセコムセキュリティ入れたってても
その人は出入りできますからね
鍵は 10枚かけてあっても
家に住んでるんだから
その人が鍵持ってるんだから
相変わらず入っていいのです
だから我々の生き方っていうのは
我々の人間の心が育てていないならば
そんなもんになるんだろう
すごい危険だと また貧乏がね
貧乏は嫌だと思ってもね
どうしようもないんです
ということは 私たちは心育ててない
しかし幸福になりたいと
心を邪悪に洗練されている
しかし 自分が極度に幸せになりたいと願っていてもダメですよ
そんなこと ありえないんですね
いやだ 私の不幸は私のせいだなんてと
ただ そんなこと言うと
みんなそんな反応するんですよ
だから仏教で言っているのは
偉そうなことを言うなよと
あんた不幸 もう幸福になりたいと思ってもできませんと
だってあなたの心悪いでしょうに
失礼ではなくて きつい言い方ですよ
人が不幸になっていると
ああ かわいそうですね
こんなのあってはならんではなくて
あんたのせいだということですよ
例えば 家が火事になったとしましょう
そこで もう家の人々は本当にものすごくショックを受けちゃって
泣いたり 財産もなくなってどうしようかといったところに私がいてね
あのね これはあなたのせいだからね
言っちゃうとすごいきついでしょうね
普通だったら まあまあ
そういうことで まあ落ち込んではきませんよと
まあ頑張ればなんとかなるんだからとかでしょ
でもそれは事実じゃないんです
ですから ブッダがこの話で言うと
誰でも あ 嫌だ 私の不幸は私のせいだなんてと思っちゃうんですね
それで言う人まで この言う人も失礼な人やと言っちゃいますよ
言われますよ でもまあ真理はそんなもんだよ
次 で まあそれからまあ救いの道もありますよという意味で
タップオンザドアイットウィルオープンという英語の言葉ですけど
叩けば開くという意味なんですね
ちょっとすっと工夫すれば心が広げていくんだよと
それもお釈迦様の言葉ですよ
ナタンマーターピタカイラアンジェーワービチャニャータカサンマーパニヒタンチッタンセイヤソーナンカトーカレ
意味は心を正しく育て育ってるならば
母にも父にも他の親戚にもしてあげることできないほど自分が優れている人間になるのです
なんか日本語おかしいね
まあ人間になるのですということで
そこでこのまた言葉はここで分析してないんです
ナタンマーターピタカイラ
我々を大事に愛しているお母さんにもできないんだよと
お父さんにもできないんだよと
私たちのことをいくら心配している大事な親戚がいたっても
やってくれることできないほどすごい良いこと
自分の心がやってくれるんですよ
サンマーパニヒタンチッタン
心が正しく洗練すると正しく育てることやってくれます
どう見たっても お母さんにできることは決まってるでしょう
いくら心配したっても
父親にできることってのはほんのわずかなものなんですよ
でも 自分の心がしっかりしているならば
どこまででも幸福になります
ですから それはまとめて言えば
敵がうちにいるので攻撃できないはずがありませんという論理になるんですよ
今前暗いこと言ったでしょ
泥棒を家の中に住んでるんだから
あんたをいくら鍵かけても
セコムを頼んでもうセキュリティつけちゃっても意味はないんだよと
盗まれるんだと だから盗まれたのはあなたのせいだと
なぜならば泥棒が家にいるんだからと
それでどうすればいいのか
家に泥棒いるんだったら攻撃するのは簡単でしょうに
逆に考えれば その論理なんですよ
例えば家に泥棒が入ったんだよと警察に言って調べて
それで警察があちこち歩き回って
まあ見つかりませんよとか
何かあの世田谷のね 殺人事件で家族一家殺されても
どこにその人がいればいまだにわからないでしょうに
だから外から来る敵だったら攻撃
本当は難しいんですよ
他人のせいに自分が不幸になるんだったら
もうお手上げ お釈迦様言うのはあなたのせいだよと
それは決して失礼なことではないんですよ
これが正しい言葉なんですね
ということは 私のふざけた言葉に言い換えて変えてみると
泥棒が家の中にいるんだったらやっつければいいでしょうに
いとも簡単にはこいつだとわかるでしょうに
そういうことだから 私たちの心を育てるということはいとも簡単にできるんです
腐ってるのは自分の心だから
それは自分で知ってるんだから
それを直せばいいんだ
だからなんですよ 前あの説明で言ったのは
この心の育て方の場合は
心の悪い原因っていうのがもう絞って仏教は明確に自覚させるんですよ
これがこれが問題だよと
各人に心の問題をね それから一般的な心が萎縮して何が悪いと
萎縮して萎縮したっていいんじゃないかなっていう考え方があるかもしれません
心が支配者であるから
幸福の原因は心にある
それは一つ一つの理由なんです
一切の行為は善か悪か心が決める
心を除くと体がただの物体です
悩みも苦しみも心に起こる現象です
体にあるものではありません
萎縮した心が行う行為は不善です
萎縮した小さい心でやっているものは何でももう決まって不善
悪いことです 不良に走った心は凶災そのものです
で 説明はまああまり要りませんね
萎縮して何が悪いんじゃなくて
心が支配者でしょうに
支配者が萎縮したらどうなりますかね
支配者が弱くて病弱で
昔 ソ連にいた誰かの大統領がいて
すごい病気で年取って取って
もうちょっと揺らっただけでも死にそうな
で ごまかしたりして すごい健康やとかね
だからそういう人々は判断しちゃうと原子爆弾を持っているわ
冗談じゃないでしょうに
だから支配者が萎縮していいわけじゃないんです
支配者こそ完全な健康
健康でいないと だから
それから幸福の原因は心でしょう
誰でも幸福になりたいでしょう
萎縮した心は我々は不幸にするんだから
萎縮していいわけじゃありません
で 次の行為は 善悪は心が決める
例えば 私が手を上げて何か殴る
殴る それ 殴ったこと悪いんですか？いいんですかね
決められません 心が決めるんですよ
手でこう何か殴っただけで
善でも悪でもないんですよ
私は紙一枚破る それは善ですか？悪ですかね
心が決めるんですよ それで私が破った紙は
私の嫌な人がいて その人の大事な契約書
心が知ってるんですよ
あいつは嫌な人や これは大事な契約書を忘れちゃったんだよ
では いいことでも あの
何て言いますか 仕返しすることができるんだと思って紙を破ると
それで私はものすごい悪いことをしてるんですよ
法律的にも裁かれる悪いことしてるんですよ
なぜそれ悪いんだ 心なんですよ
そこでそちらいた猫が来て
その上でぐちゃぐちゃ遊んだとします
それで紙がぐちゃぐちゃになったとします
猫が爪とぐ時はもう紙の上で研いだとします
それで壊れたいでしょうね
別に猫に罪がないんですよ
そんなことわかんないんだから
考えてもないんだから
だから紙が破った故に罪ということは言えませんよ
その破らせた心で決めるんです
手を挙げて殴ったら罪だと言えません
手を上げさせた 殴らせた心が決めるんですよ
赤ちゃんもおっぱい飲んでお腹がいっぱいになっちゃうと
もうどんどんと殴るでしょうね
お母さんの体を 別にもう何のことないでしょう
それが赤ちゃんが楽しくて
お母さんのことはもうもう可愛くて
もうそれで愛情表現で殴ってるんですよ
だからそれは悪になりません
そういうこと で 次なんでしたっけ？うん
そこで我々の心 体から心が抜けちゃうとね
ただの物体 それよく理解してほしい
そんな体に何か聖なるもの何もあるわけじゃない
ただの肉ですよ 肉と骨ですよ
簡単に腐敗腐らせてしまうしね
だからこれが生き物として生きているということは心なんですね
全部心なんですね ですから心は大事ですよ
悩み苦しむ心で生まれるもの
だから悩み苦しみをなくせますよ
もし足で悩んでるんだったら
足で足のせいで苦しんでるんだったらどうしますかね
足を切断するしかないでしょうね
この頭 これでこの丸いこれで苦しんでるのこれ切って捨てるしかないでしょうね
そんなもんで困ることはないんですよ
結局 苦しみ悩みっていうのは心が作るんですから
まだ心は治りますから
そういうことで 萎縮した心は良くないということになります
[咳]で 一番この下にあることはよく理解してほしい
萎縮した心が行う行為は不善ですということ
それ我々は暗い心で 小さな心で狭い心でやることはよく見てください
何でも悪いことなんですよ
心が大きくて 広くて 楽しくて
明るい時とか 悪いことはしないんですよ
まあ子供でも万引きしたりする場合は
すごくこの心がいろんなことで悩んで落ち込んで
嫌でイライラ状態で心がガタガタなんです
その時は だからなんとかもうやろうと思って万引きしたりする
万引きは悪いことでしょうに
だから心が 萎縮した心がやることは何でも悪い
それでこの子供のことを思っていると思って勘違いして
このヒステリーになって子供虐待したりするでしょ
お母さんたちが 虐待しているんだけど
子供は本当に可愛いんですよ
なんでそうなるんですかというと
育児ヒステリーで心がずっと萎縮するんですよ
だから子供は可愛いことには変わりありません
この前テレビでアメリカの映像を見たんですけど
なんか子供を引っ張って車にこうやって投げ捨てて
バンバンと殴るんですよ
見ていられない ものすごい勢い
それでビデオに撮られて逮捕されちゃったんですけどね
で 刑務所いて私はもう子供のことすごく可愛いんだと
なんでああいうことをするかわかりませんと
そこで権利も全部奪われたんですけど
その人は だから そのお母さんの場合も
ヒステリーで育児ノイローゼでいろんなことで心が萎縮しちゃうんですね
そうするとやることは何でも悪い
ですから 萎縮した心は危険です
この一番下にあるぐらい不良に走った心は重罪そのものですと
これ不良に走ったというのは
私はもういい加減に言えた言葉で
心が悪い方向へ育ちちゃうと
その心があること自体罪ですよ
これ一番危険なんです
これは仏教で言うの邪見という言葉を使っています
だから罪のリストの中で一番重い罪っていうのは邪見なんですね
そうすると一般的に考える人だと
これは誰でも言ってることやと
どんな宗教の人も 自分の宗教で言ってることは正見で
他のものを全部邪教邪教と言ってるんではないの？同じことではないかと思うかもしれません
思うんですよ だから そういうことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様は お釈迦様は逆に私の教えは正しい
他人の教えは間違っているということは間違っているんだよと言ってますからね
成り立たない そういうことは
ですから このこちらで言ってるのは
この心が汚くなって汚くなって萎縮して
変な思考で まあどうにもならんな状態になる
もう改良しようと思ったっても
もうお手上げ状態になると
そうすると その心そのものが罪です
どういうことか その心その人で生きてるでしょうに
それから死んでも その心のせいで生まれ変わったりするでしょうに
決していいところには行けない
全くも幸福にならない
喋っても見ても 座っても立っても罪を犯している
ですから この邪悪に走った心
邪悪世間になった心がそのものは罪で
仏教は見ているんです
普通は行為なんですけどね
喋ったり考えたりする行為が罪だというでしょ
善悪の場合は正しい思考は善で
悪い思考は不善で 正しい言葉は善で
悪いことは不善だと行為で言ってますけど
やっぱりリストの中で心そのものは不善である
邪悪に走ったことということを言ってますから
萎縮して何か悪いということにはなりません
とっても危険なことよ
心を育てないことは ものすごい
もうこれ以上危険なことないと思ってもらわないと
もう真理から外れます
心すべてになるんですよ
はい  これからあの もうちょっと分析的なところに行きます
で 心の上に 5つの重しがあるんだと
なんで心がドーンと広げて活動しないかというと
これ重しが 5つももう入れてるんですよ
これがリスト 1番目カーマチャンド
五欲に惹かれる  2番目ビャーパード
怒りに悩ませる  3番目ティーナミッド
睡眠や怠けることが好き
4番目ウッダ っちゃ くっいっちゃ落ち着きがない
後悔して落ち込む  ５番目
リチキっちゃ 理性の揺らぎ
何でも疑う わからないんだから
よく調べると もう人間っていうのはそんなものでしょう
これでできてるんですよ
だから心は成長するはずがないんですよ
もう 五欲に惹かれない人がいますか？怒りに悩まない人がいますか
怠けることを好き 何もしないでいること好きでしょ
落ち着かない なんかすぐ落ち着けなくなっちゃう
ちょっと問題起きたらもうすぐ落ち着かない
それから落ち着かないで失敗するのは決まってるんでしょうしね
失敗すると あーいやだ
なんでまたやったんですか？なんでまた
そればっかりで人生落ち着かない人は
それで 5番目 まあどうせないんだから
理性っていうのは感情で考えてるんだから
はい で ただの説明 心が本来えーと持っているはずの能力が発揮しない原因はこの 5つです
この 5つの重石で心が抑えられて手も足も出ない状態でいるのです
自分の心は暗くて苦しいのだとわかっていますが
一向に外へ出る勇気がないのです
そこまでは理解してほしい
で 私たちにはどうしようもない状態で誰でもいるんですよ
何やってもなんかどうしようもない
すぐこの 何て言いますか
制限リミットが見えちゃうんですよ
私はここまでやと いつでも何やってもやっぱりここまでやと
だから大人になってくると
かなり人間というのは暗いんですよ
あのまあ 子供はリミットを知らんから
何ができるかわからないんだからね
かなり明るく言うんですけど
逆にそれも子供にとって苦しいんですよ
どんな勉強をするでしょうかと
これからはね 高校でどんな学問を選ぶでしょうかとかね
これかなり苦しむんですよ
で その時はリミットが見えないんですね
リミットが見えなくても苦しいし
これでちょっと年取るともうはっきり見えるんですね
自分の正体は それでまた苦しいんですよ
だからそれはもうこの 5つのせいなんです
それわかってます それは良くないとわかってますけど
我々にとってはどうしようもないんですね
理由は簡単です 私たちは心の成長を妨げる 5つの原因は好きでたまらないのです
苦痛なんですよ この自分に邪魔しているものが好きなんですよ
その 5つに依存しているのです
成長したいと思っていても
探し求めるのは他でもなく
この 5つそのものです
我々は成長しようと思って
五欲を探して怒りを探してるんですよ
これ好きだからもう飼ってるんですよ
大事なペットなんですよ
ずっと一緒に生活している
なんかもうクマやら虎やらライオンやら
そのような動物をペットで飼っているような感じなんですよ
もう大変ですよ 虎なんか飼っちゃうと餌でも並じゃないんだから
それで管理は大変でしょうし
お金はかかるし 危険であるし
あらゆる決まりがもうその地方によって出てくるし
日本では虎飼えるかどうか法律でわかりませんですけど
アメリカなんか飼ってるみたいですけどね
だからそんなものを飼ってみるとどうですかね
しかし その人はそれ そのペットが好きで好きでたまらんだったらどうしますかね
もうどうしようもないですよ
好きで好きでたまらない自分のペット
この虎が しかし養うこともできないし
そんな状態で我々は心の 5つの重しをペットにしているんです
で まあ無駄遣いで金がなくなった人は
その苦しみから脱出するためにサラ金に手を伸ばすものと同じですと
どんどん増えるだけと
無駄遣いしてお金がなくなったら
もうサラ金からお金を貸して無駄遣いだから
この人は お金借りてもらったらもっとひどくなるでしょう
それでもその人はやっぱりあれやりたい
これやりたい 無駄遣いの気持ちはそのままです
またお金借りることになります
そこで全部奪われて殺されちゃいます
だからその現象で理解してください
この重しに対して あの
我々は本当にペットのように育ててます
そこで理性がないとそういうことなんです
はい それで大丈夫ですね
で 次は苦悩は楽しむと苦を求む
苦悩は楽として苦を求む
それは当たり前のことですね
苦悩ということ 苦悩が楽です
楽しみだよと思ったら何を求めるんですかね
そうすると苦を求めるんですよ
勘違いですけどね 勘違いは必ずあるんです
これで我が心がさらに萎縮するのです
ということで それでつの説明に行きます
1番目は欲の依存症 で
五感から入る刺激を楽しむ
それ以外は楽しみが楽しみないと楽しみがないという潜入感
この文字通り理解してください
我々は五感から入る情報
これが楽しみだと 見るもの
聞くもの 味わうもの 嗅ぐもの
体で触れる ああ 楽しい
これが楽しい どれどれ楽しいかとと思ってます
それだけじゃなくて これ以外楽しみがないんだと
立派な家を作って 高価な外国輸入の家具を買って
高価な絨毯を敷いて そこら辺であったかくして
もう楽しいんだよ 贅沢だ
生きていて良かったと
そんな気持ちでいるんですよ
その人々はこれ以外 別にも楽しみがあるんだってことを知らない
それは潜入感なんです
この潜入感のせいで 私たちは五感の情報に依存している
それは病気です で  これから読みますかね
誰かに読んでもらったら
まあなんだか色相こう民宿から
これはつですね 離れなくなる
それに執着する かなり狭い殻が現れる
に 誰にでも狭いから 自分の目に入るもの
耳に入るもの その殻が現れるんですよ
知識 能力は五つから得る刺激に限る
人間の知識っていっても
能力って言ったっても
あの刺激からあの殻の中のもんですよ
すごい小さいもんで 楽しみは主観的なものなので
知識も主観的で大したことではありません
こんなこと言うと怒られるかもしれませんだけど
まあ仏教から見れば 人間の知識っていうのはね
なんだか大したことはないんだと
ああ そうかいってことで終わるんですよ
すごいすごいすごい本書いてきたってもね
みんなびっくりするほどいろんな研究したじゃせちゃっても
で終わるぐらい なぜならばね
自分の知識でも五感から入る情報しか何もないんだからね
それから楽しみでしょ
だから楽しみっていうのは主観的なものなんですね
その楽しみに没すぎて考えたり勉強したりする
数学やってる人は数学を楽しんでるし
音楽している人はそこでそれを楽しんでるんですよ
哲学の本書いてる人は思考で楽しんでるんですよ
だから結局は五欲を楽しむことはやってるんですよ
だから五欲を楽しむっていうことは主観的なんですよ
それはわかりますかね
例えばおにぎりを持ってきて
美味しいかろくな食べ物ではありませんというのは
人々の主観でしょ おにぎりのせいじゃないんです
ある人はおにぎり これこそごちそうだと言うかもしれません
あなた なんでこんなもんで食べるか
もっと立派なものを食べたいと思うかもしれません
だから おにぎりが美味しいかないかということは
豪華かないかということは主観なんです
音楽聴いて素晴らしい音楽ね
それ主観なんです だったら哲学を勉強して楽しむ人
それ主観なんですよ 哲学的な質問で楽しいという人の気持ちわかりますかね？私はわかります
私にとっては だからふざけていることは楽しいんですから
それ私の主観で 何もしないでいろいろふざけて
いろんなことをガチャガチャやってることは
私は楽しい 哲学本なんか開けちゃうと
もう決して楽しくない
バカと付き合えないんだよと言って捨てるんです
しかし そういうバカとよく付き合ってる人々いますよ
一生 だから哲学を勉強する人も素晴らしい知識人だが
仏教はいらないんですよ
ただ自分の主観の世界で楽しんでるんだよと
数学を研究してノーベル賞を取るぐらいの新しい何か法則を発見したと言ったっても
まあそれも同じことで
自分の主観の世界で楽しんで何かしたということですよ
ですから そんな知識なんかは仏教から見ると依存症があるんだからね
大したことではありませんですね
えーと やれないんだ ポインターがないんだから
どこを行ったかわからない
あ すぐやりますかね はいはい
いいやいい えーと そこはね
刺激を楽しむ 刺激の楽しみでは
満足が得られないという事実に遭遇するが
諦めないのです これ みんな遭遇しますよ
何をしても満足得られないんですよ
納得いかない しかし 諦めないで頑張る
で 五欲の中でより良い
より刺激的なものを探す
しかし 満足は得られない
これが悪循環なんです
ですから 心は壮大しない
難しい考え方なんですけど
まあ論理的にまとめてまとめて言えばそんなことになるんですね
だから 例えば勉強して満足っていうことないんですよ
研究して満足っていうことはない
もしかするともっとできるんじゃないかなと
もしかして別の人だったらもっと立派なことをやるんじゃないかなと
自分が美人だからといって満足できんですよ
まあ美人は美人ですけど
もっと美人がいるんじゃねえかなとか
という気持ちになるんですよ
だから満足を得られないということも真理です
満足を得られないとみんな諦めないんだから
もっといいものを探そう
で 頑張っちゃう そうするともっといいもの見つかるかも
見つかって満足しないんだから
もっといいものを探そう
それ見つけてももっといいものさ
どこまで行くんですかと
だからいいもの 大きければ
もっと苦しみも大きくなっちゃうし
見つからなかったらものすごい苦しくなっちゃうし
それでこの悪循環になるんですね
だから我々はいくら食べても諦めないし
いくら遊んでももうもっと遊びたいし
寝てももっと寝たいし
いつでもね 成功してもっと成功したいし
金持ちになってもっと金持ちになりたいし
終わり これが離れないものだから依存症になるんですね
依存症っていうのはすごい危険なもので
えーと だから心は壮大しない
各自の狭い殻の殻に閉じ込まれるのです
けれども 苦しいのに 悪いことにこの副産物もおまけについてくるのです
これ 五欲で苦しいんですけど
副産物もおまけについてくるんですよ
それは恐怖感 競争 自信消失
落ち込み 失望 裏切り 怒り
憎しみ たくさんあります
欲の世界全部あるでしょ
そんなのはすべておまけ
確実に付いているんです
離れないんです はい それから怒りの生生
五感から入る情報をえー
何ですかね 拒否して逆らう気持ちです
怒りっていうのは この五感から情報入ると拒否して逆らいたくなっちゃうんです
ですから 欲からハメることではなく
好み情報があって それと違う情報が入ると時怒る感情です
あ 五感の情報拒否しているんだから
なんかブッダみたいになったんではないかと
それじゃないんですよ
本当は好みがあるんですよ
この好みが入ってこないんですよ
これじゃなくて嫌ですよ
これは ということなんですよ
だからそばを食べたがって
そば食べたい食べたいと言ったところで
ご飯を持ってくると怒るんですよ
それで悟ったわけじゃないんです
この人はご飯見て全然もう欲が出てこないねとかね
だから欲があること心に起こるんですよ
情報を受け入れらない状態になり
攻撃態勢をとる 怒ったらどうなるかというと
この外から情報入るでしょ
それを拒否するんですね
そうすると情報入らないんですよ
それではなくて 自分は硬くなって攻撃態勢に心がいくんです
心が暗くなる そうすると攻撃が相手を壊すよりも
より先に自分自身を壊すのです
そこで攻撃しようとじっと硬くなるんだから
それで壊れるんですよ
これは心の法則なんですね
例えば あのー 鉄砲で人を撃つんだったら安心ですけど
そういう道具がないんだから
心にはね 自分自身で体当たりしなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分が毒にならないと相手に毒を回すことができないんですよ
それは心のやり方なんです
だから あの人を潰そうと言っちゃうと
潰すエネルギーが自分を潰るんですよ
もう潰されます いわゆるこんなこと
人 家 人の家になんて言いますか
放火したいと思っちゃう
ものすごい怒ってる その人はもう何も持ってない
その人のできる唯一のことは
体中にガソリンをまいて
自分の体に火をつけて家に飛び込むことです
それでどうなるんですかね？誰が先に死ぬんですかね
自分が先に死ぬんです
これは自爆テロでも同じことでね
それが心の法則です だから怒りが出ると
攻撃態勢に入ると もう心がもう毒を作って
もう自己破壊体制になっているんです
だから間違ってでも怒ってはいけないんだ
大敵に 怨敵にしたっても穏やかになる
ブッダが教えるのはそういうわけなんです
怨敵だからしょうがないんではないかとかね
やっぱり悪い人を潰しては
潰さなきゃこれは正義にならんぞとかね
そういうのは真理わからない一般人の思考なんです
だから怒りっていうのはもうそのまま炎でそのものが燃える
燃やそう 本人は活発になったつもりですが
この感情がある人は自分の家に鍵をかけて火遊びして火事にしているのです
活発ですが すぐ消失します
消失です 自爆活動ですね
だからこの自爆活動を我々はずっとやっています
ということで 怒りが出ると瞬間で
これは自爆だと思わないと
ずっとこのスッタニパータでも
１番目の経典っていうのは全部怒りに対してずっと喋ってますよ
怒りが生まれたら すぐ蛇が脱皮するようにすぐ捨てなさいと
でないとどうなるかわからない
で 嫌な体操は忘れればいいのに
心から全くの離れないないでしがみつくものです
これもなんかややこしいことですよ
嫌なことだったら忘れちゃえばいいでしょうに
嫌なことは忘れちゃえばいいです
これ 推理もしがみつくんですよ
好きな人のことよりも
嫌な人のことはいつまでも頭の中でもう離れないんですよ
だから怒りが出て出て燃えて
人はダメにするんですね
はい だから理性がないっていうのはそういうことなんですよ
あの人は可愛い 私は好きですって言ったら
その人のことを思えばいいのに
あの人 なんであの人あんなことするんですか？なんであんなことを喋るんですか？とか
その嫌なことはずっと思っている
これ何 10年で思っている
次は聞いてみいて 貪瞋
もうやっと見つけたんです
この漢字が すごい苦労しました
この今日聞いたこの貪瞋の漢字見つけるとそういうの間違ってるんですね
見つけ間違ってます あの心なんとか入ります
左側に 何と読みますか？あれは
一心弁 え？そうなんだ
で あの一応見つけたんですけど
入ってないんですね もしかするとこちらでなかったかな
貪瞋では出ない それは文字のリストを出して
あった  いた  あ そう  そうしたんでは
そうそう あ ちょっと違うわ
え？ あ これでいいんですね
え？痴がいいんです 進むこと
それでいい で そこで再生をできら...ないね
再生してくれるか また始まるな
[笑い]たまたまこちら左
右側出ますよ  そこら辺で
まああの本日 これまあまああまり難しくないと思いますけどね
あの 眠り姫ということで
よく寝たいというね あの寝ることが好き
腰が重く あまり動きたくない
活動しないで座り込んでいることは楽しい
チャレンジ的なものは全くもいや
保守気取りで変化は好まない
それはすべて説明は 私はこのちょっとふざけた言葉なんですが
この定義全部入れてるんですよ
例えば一つの保守き取りっていうのは
だから直らないんですよ
変化嫌で いや こんなことやったらダメですよとかね
結局心の中でこの重しがあって
もういわゆる革命的に動きたくないんですよ
自分が正しいと思っちゃうんです
だから まあだから私はもうわざと保守気取りというような感じなんですけど
これは怠けですと 単純に
そういう性格はある意味でいくらでいくらでいるでしょうね
新しいことを新しいものが出てくると
なんだこの今頃世界は
とかね なんだ今頃の人間はとかね
と言いながら自分が欲しき出る
本当は怠け者で新しいものはしたくない
これはそういう人の心は成長しない
これはすごい面白いになるんです
で 睡眠を楽しむことも依存症になります
寝れば寝るほどもっと眠たくなってしまうのです
寝すぎことは決して健康な状態ではありません
心の活動は極力低下します
寝ているものは何もありません
怒りが出やすい人間にもなります
あまり寝すぎな人間になっちゃうと
結構怒りも出やすくなるんです
人間として確実に堕落します
だから インターネットで文句を言いましたからね
なんで眠ることに文句を言うんでしょうか
すごい健康な体が必要でしょうかと言ったってもね
その人の機嫌を取ってあげるわけにはいきません
まあ一応インターネットだから機嫌取っていますけど
言いたいことは別にあるんですよ
で  こういう これ病気です
普通 医学的に考えても
あの 寝ると寝ると脳がそのままでもっともっともっともっと寝たくなるんですよ
だからこの睡眠時間というのはいくらでも伸ばせます
だから危険ですから できるだけ短くするのは頑張った方がいいんです
それぐらいのことですね
あの なんで昏沈睡眠とか言ったかというと
この睡眠でもみんな分かりますけど
睡眠で昏沈っていうのはなんかいつでもこんな感じで頭だけってなんかもう動かない状態
動きたくない状態 だからそれもありますね
寝るってわけでもない
例えば普通に寝る人々いますよ
いるんだけど なんかあまり行動的じゃないというね
じゃあさっさと進んでいきましょうか
それで 5番目 ウッダッチェ
クックッチェ それは落ち着きがない
よく後悔する 真面目なつもりですが
結局は神経質だけ  この 3 4番目の人は
だから皆様にわかるのは真面目な人ということ
だから軽々くあの人真面目
あの人真面目と決めるんじゃなくて
よく見てください ちゃったらただの神経質よ
結果としてなさることは何でも中途半端です
そういう人々は それで失敗が多いから後悔することも絶えない
何にも集中できない 何でも見たり
聞いたり 話したり やったりしようとするから
活発な人間だと自分 思い込むが
自分が思い込むが 実は集中力がなくて落ち着きがないだけです
後悔もこの性格におまけに付きますと
ちょっともう複雑に考えて書いてますけど
あの 私たち俗的な俗的な目で見ると結構動いていると
あれもやってこれもやって
あっちもやって こっちもやってとかね
会社でも仕事をするわ
もう家のことにもなんか手を出すわ
社会のことにも手を出すわ
友達のことにはもうまた手紙も書くわ
また文章も書いてみろ
本も書いてみろ 歌も書いてみろとかね
スポーツもやってサッカーじゃなく何ですか？ってあれ
[笑い] ゴルフに行こうとか
やることいっぱいある
なんかすごい活発だけですね
本当は それで心が成長
成長しないでしょう だから問題です
それをみんなわかってないんですよ
ちゃんと時間で作るで
5時半で起きて  30分散歩をして
それで 6時にまあなんとかして
それから新聞読んで それからご飯を食べて
また 6時半にゴルフに行って
それから帰って仕事に行って
なんとかとか また夜 11時半まで 12時まで
もう秒単位で 1 分単位でスケジュールがある
やることは様々複雑です
誰でもああ 羨ましいなと思うんですよ
それでその人は精神的に成長しているかと
本当は何一つろくにやってないんですよ
毎日 1時間ぐらいゴルフやっただけで
あれも何も役にも立ちませんし
だからそんなことでね
ちょっとだけ歌一つ書いてみたんだけど
不思議にならないんですよ
ちょっと楽器なんか弾いてみたらとか
ちょっと楽器持ってきちゃったな
まあ明日また練習するぞとかね
今日は私は毎日 20 分練習するんだよとかね
それもやってあれもやってて
何一つもものにならない
なんでそういう性格になるかというと
落ち着きがない 神経質
だから何でも失敗のは決まっている
ものになってないのは決まっている
それで後悔する おまけに
忙しかったんだから あれできなかったとかね
で そこがすごい まあ何でも勇者になりますよ
で 後悔して落ち込むのに自分が良い人間だと錯覚しますので
これ覚えてください このよく後悔する人
人にも私のところに来たんだけど
いくら言っても言っても
もう明るくしなさいよと
私は若いのに開き直れと
そんな開き直るなんか
こんな悪いことして 私はね
それはとんでもない できるわけないでしょ
開き直る言葉自体悪いんだと
私 何が悪くわかりませんですけどね
私は平気で言うんですよ
どんな どんな悪いことをして悩んできたってね
開き直れ 私はそれ言うところで終わりですよ
忘れちゃえ でもそんなことで
またもうあれは千里ごろんですよ
私はいい人間やと これで自分がダメになるだけなんですよ
錯覚ですよ だから治らない病気なんですよ
自分がいい人間だと思ってるんだから
治るわけないでしょう
いい人間だと思ってとんでもない後悔のことをやっちゃうと
で 後悔は自分をいじめて楽しむことです
それは自分をいじめて楽しむ
反省する人は二度と同じ過ちを犯さないのが犯さないが
この人は決して変わらない
後悔する人は必ずしも同じ過ちは何回もする
いつしか過ちをする 反省した人は二度と同じことをしません
反省には客観的な観察が必要です
誰にでも反省できるわけじゃないんです
すごい智慧が必要で 理性が必要です
反省するために客観的な判断能力が必要ですね
だから このかっこつけて言葉を使うのは
私は反対 それはそういうわけなんですよ
普通日本語だったら まあじゃあ反省しましょうとかね
できるわけないんですよ
だからできるのは開き直ることですよ
ああ そんな悪いことをやってやりませんとかね
私は言葉を選んで言ってるんです
能力ない人に 理性がない人に
ものの判断できない人に
この観察する実践していない人に
反省しなさいと言っても成り立たないんですよ
それはちゃんと修行で観察能力を得た人には反省できます
こういうこういう原因で
この子のことで この子のふうに私は対応したんだから
こういう間違いを起こしました
そういうことで じゃあこれこれ直せばよろしい
それが反省なんです だから普通の方々
私に相談に来て 私は節操のない言葉で感じしますけど
本当のところは節操のない言葉ではなくて
その人がその言葉しか知らない
だから私は堂々とこれからも言います
何か悪いことをして反省するんだったら開き直りなさい
それはできるはずなんですよ
反省はできない 正しいもの反省
それはわかってますよ
しかし 能力のない人はどうしますかね
何かすると調べたいんだと私に頼んだら
私はそれにはドイツ語でいい本がありますよと言ってドイツ語の本を出します
そうすると 私はドイツ語っていうのはあべこべも知りませんよ
でも あなたに必要な情報はここにありますから
はい これを読んでくださいと言ったとしても意味がないでしょうに
それで その人が調べたいことには
子供向きに漫画描いて漫画があって
その漫画に 1部説明があると
それで私は堂々とあの漫画を読んでください
だってドイツ語の本にちゃんと専門的なことがあっても読めないんだから
だったら読める漫画にある情報が情報で自分の問題解決するしかないんです
そういうことだから 開き直ってください
後悔するたびに罪が重なるのです
それも覚えておいてください
かっこつけて後悔しても
今度は同じ罪の重さがどんどんどんどん重なっていくんです
で それが疑の説明  5番目疑いの説明
これすごい難しいんです
判断能力 何でしたっけ？結晶というのは日本語でないんです
そんなの だからあまり困らないでください
もう私 勝手に作るんです
で 情報の処理能力がないと判断もできません
判断ができないと行動が止まります
曖昧で何普段と言うんですか？優柔不断でいることになります
この人は何を知っても成長はないのです
自立できなくなる 流されないように気をつけているつもりですが
他人の判断に見事に流されて一生終わります
これが説明しないとわからないと思いますよ
この 5番目の重しっていうのは
この専門用語で義と書くんですね
疑いという漢字 そう言うと
みんな疑うことは悪くないと思っちゃうんですよ
でも 仏教はそれを病気で扱ってるんですよ
疑いってどういうことかというと
この自分に入るあらゆる情報がありますね
五欲五欲の世界ですけど
その情報って何なのかわからないんですね
判断できないんですよ
この判断能力できないんだから
まあなんとなくやる なんとなくする
だから大体よく聞いてる言葉でしょ
みんなやってるんだからやってますと
今流行ってるんだからやってますと
あれはこの重しのせいなんです
だから自分で判断するならば
今流行っていても 私はやりませんということになります
で 私はいろいろこの医学的な新しいものを発見しましたとかね
新しいもう抜群の奇跡的なもうもう治るがんが治る食べ物があるんだぞとか言うと
説明来ちゃうと まあやめましょうと
わかるんですよ 見て情報入っただけで
まあこれがもう言ってることは大したことないとか判断する能力があると
なるほど 納豆食べてみようかな
腸がんなくなるんだから
そういう感じで テレビで言ったんだからとかね
大体もうテレビで言ったんだから
コマーシャルで流されたんだから
時々インターネットでもね
品物が売ってるんですよ
あの話題のテレビコマーシャルになったものはいかがでしょうか？って誰が買うんですかね
話題のテレビコマーシャルになったんだから
品物が良ければ買うんだよ
しかし 判断能力ない人は
やっぱりもうそれでも優柔不断状態になる
それでこのカッコつけるんですよ
私はね そう簡単に決められません
決めませんよとね そう簡単にね
あんた言ったって乗りませんよとかね
カッコつけてるんですよ
では 自分に判断できるか
できないんですね それでよく見ると
見事に流されているんです
あなたの話には乗せませんよと
やってはいけないことなんですよ
私もそれやるんですよ
で 来る人々の中で えらいこの義で
私はもうしっかりした人間だから
あんた方どうでってことで
なんか私は憎というか
それです そういう人々
すごい簡単 もう知って弱み知ってるんだから
判断能力ないんだけど
だからやっぱりこのコントローラーを知っていると怖いんですよ
もうものすごい管理できるしね
で いろいろ人のことも浮かぶんだけどね
ただ疑う性格もあります
ただ疑うというね とにかく疑うという
これは並ならぬ悩みの原因になります
結局は あれも疑う これも疑うと
例えば旦那が浮気しているのでは？とかね
もしかすると私のことを嫌になっているのでは？とかね
うんぬんの疑いのウイルスが入ったら
精神状態はどのようなものでしょうかね
そういう性格もあるでしょ
なんとなく疑うんですよ
もしかすると旦那が浮気しているのではと
これ悲しいんですかね
疑うだけなら何でも疑える
だから疑う症が入っちゃうと何でも疑えるんですよ
人が水いっぱい持ってきたら
本当にこれ大丈夫でしょうかね？あんたカップガラス洗ったんですかね？とかね
これ水道の水でしょうねとか
あるいはビルだからおそらく貯水タンクがあって
あの水は この間聞いたんですよ
ネズミももう 3匹ぐらい死んで腐っていたんだとかね
それで疑うならば何でも疑えますよ
この人 水飲みたくなっちゃいます
それでそのビルに登って管理人から許可もらって
あの水タンクを開けて調べて
ああ ネズミがない では飲みますと
できますかね だから疑うっていうこと
もうやってはいけないんですよ
幸福なんかすぐ壊れてしまいます
で 心は消えない 山火事のような状態になる
まあ当たり前だから その時はね
確実な証拠を調べるのではなく
私の勘だ そのような気がするなどで疑いを養っては苦しむ
この証拠を探さない人々は平気で言うでしょ
あの人はもう もう旦那が本当に浮気
浮気しているんだよ なんで知ってるんだい？これは私の勘だよ
もうこれで終わりですよ
もう人生は あるいはなんとなく私はそんな気がしますよとかね
とんでもないことなんですよ
みんなすごい見栄張っていてやってますけどね
私の勘が鋭いぞとかね
バカ言えと こちらに言うなよと言いたいんですけどね
勝手にして下さい だから勘と言った途端
証拠がないということをわかってるんだからね
だから私はもうこの間も誰か誰かとの分相を直したりする時は
まあここら辺はまあ私の勘なんですけど
95%当たりますよと
その時も私は勘ですよとなぜ言うかというと
あの 確実に私は調べていない
仏教のことなんですけど
何か新しい意見を出しちゃうと
これは私の勘なんですけどと言ったところで
もう調べていないことを発言しているんです
別に私は紙に載ってるわけじゃないんです
ここで 95%当たりますよというのは
まあいつでもそうやって証拠で論理的に考えているんだから
まあそうやたらに勘は作りません
いわゆる仮説ということなんです
だから勘というのはもうもう勘弁してほしいものなんですよ
はい でも治らないんですね
で 義が義を呼ぶので悪循環になるのです
自分を苦しむ妄想を楽しんでいることになるのです
心を成長するつもりはないのです
しかし またあります この理性に基づいた疑とは違います
これは正しい疑なんです
これから次の段落は しかしのしかしたから
理性に基づいて出てくる疑は大丈夫ですよ
例えば人は殺されている
そこで誰かがその部屋から出て行くのは目撃する
そうすると警察に言う
何々さんがその家から出て行ったよと慌てて怯えている
そうすると疑が成り立つのですね
もしかするとその人は犯人で犯人ではないかと
それはしょうがないんですよ
しかし 犯人ではない その人は臆病者で
人の友人の家に入ってみたら人が死んでいて
慌てて逃げてしまった
もう警察に言うことも全部忘れちゃったと
頭パニック状態になっちゃった
で 怯えていると 隠れている
そういうこともあり得るんですよ
だから しかし まだまだ証拠は全部揃ってないんだから
疑はかかっています 疑いはかかっている
それは別にしょうがない
それが悪循環ではないんですよ
だから正しい疑はこれなんですよ
だからこのリーズナブルダウトという英語で言えば
日本語はわからなくなっちゃうと英語を書くんです
バレますけど で 十分な証拠がないから判断をペンディングにする
ペンディングのカタカナ発音がわからなくて
そのまま書いちゃったんです
ペンディングという日本語使いますね
保留 まあ日本語でもペンディングということは使いますね
だから十分な証拠がないんだから
判断は一応保留状態にする
それも疑なんですけど
リーズナブルダウト いわゆる根拠があって疑うと
この人は証拠が揃ったら判断するのです
で 先者は勘で威張って証拠を調べないので
先策に迷う人 で 納得がいくまで判断しないのは知恵の働きです
そこで後者と書いてないんですけど
まあ後者は智慧の人で
納得いくまで判断しない
判断は保留にする 納得いくまで証拠を調べる
だからその疑は 仏教はお釈迦様は堂々とやってください
でなきゃあんた方は成長しないんだよ
とことん調べなさいよ
決めつけ 決めつけるなよ
ブッダ自身のことも言うんですよ
あんた方には超能力もないし
他心数もないし それで私がブッダだよと私が勝手に言ってるんだよ
おまじないみたいなのあります
私は煩悩はなくなりました
完全に悟っていると私は言ってるんだよ
しかし あんた方にはね
私の心は読めないわ 超能力もないわ
他心数と何でもないんだ
だったら疑えと  疑う この経典のタイトルもそれなんですよ
信じ込むね 疑って正しく理性的に論理的に疑いなさい
疑って調べなさいよ この人は本当に煩悩がないと言ってるんだけど
本当にないんですかね？とかね
ずっとすりっきりで喋る
話し方 歩き方 生き方 何から何まで調べなさい
そうするとあなたたちには
この何て言いますか こういう推測ができるんだと
こんな喋り方は煩悩ある人にはおそらく無理でしょうと
ずっと調べたんだけど
こういう風な言葉ばっかり喋っていて
もしかすると煩悩がないかもしれませんと
そのように自分のことさえもブッダが教えています
だから仏教で認めているんです
それ  2番目は 納得いくまで
まあ話しない その知恵の働き
これは成長の原因です
データが足らなくて決められない状態は問題ありません
ただし リーズナブルダウトは釈迦さんがではなく
ウィーマンセナという言葉を使っているんです
疑という言葉を使っていない
ウィーマンセナ ウィーマンセナは訳する場合はエクスプロレーション
エクスプロー 調べる 探すという意味になるんですね
まあ英語ではたくさんエクスプロー
インクワイアいろいろありますけどね
この 5つの重石でみんなまあ
心が狭くなって動かなくなっているんです
だから仏教の世界観から見ると
世間で言ってることとは完全に違うんですよ
厳密に絞って言ってるんです
で 次に行きます で まとめ
まとめは骨式 骨主席のテスト
まあ読めばわかると思いますけどね
で ものを乞うことは骨式の仕事です
プロの骨式 骨主席 実を身に染みて仕事に
何て言ったかな 間違ってますね
もに 身に染みてないと仕事にならないのですね
直しましょう うん うん
うん 骨主席が服はボロボロになればなるほど喜ぶ
汚れた方が臭い方が良いのです
醜いこと 障害があることなどは最高に恵まれている
病気になっ 病気にでもなったらまた儲けたもんです
皆さんあまり考えたことないんですから
あまり骨主席の経験ないでしょ
これはもう経験あるんだから
骨主席なんですか？乞食なんですか？ 何でしょうかね
あの お坊さんがやるのは乞食って言うんですけど
単にあの  乞食と書くと別な漢字が出てくるんだから
ベガスというね  違うね
でも長老がおっしゃってるのは乞食のような
乞食 うん ベガーというね
プロパーという じゃあ書き換えましょう
字はこれでいいんです
あ そうですか あ 発音 えっ？えっ？何？ 読み方ね
あ 乞食 読み方で意味が変わる
なるほどなるほど 私は別な漢字あると勘違いしてて
出しちゃったら別な漢字が出ますからね
はい 乞食にします で まあ乞食っていうのは皆様にはできないので
私にとってはもうかなり経験あって
不幸を喜ぶんですよ 例えばボロボロふぶけてると
こうやってもすごい楽しい
喜んでるんです これプロだから
そうでないと何もらわないんですね
病気になると全然もう治療しようか何でもなく
もうできるだけひどくなるまで寝るんですね
それでこんなことでも歩けないんだ
食べられないんだ 仕事できないんだと言って
もうものを買うんですよ
実際の不幸よりも何倍も強調して不幸を演出する
乞食は もしもお節介の人が乞食に綺麗な服を与えて
風呂に入れて治療してして
住むところも 用意してあげたら
あげたなら その行動は乞食に嫌われるのです
乞食はそれ嫌なんですよ
皆様そう違うと思うんでしょ
自分のお寺にもいろいろあの稼ぐぐるみで時々来たら
なんか子供なんか見ちゃうと
まあこいつらの面倒を見てあげたっていいんじゃないかと思っちゃう時もありますよ
で 話してみたら どうですかと
子供をこちらにくれと
ちゃんとくよくよさせて育てますよと
嫌がるんですよ ものすごく反対する
怒って帰る ご飯もいりません
そんなもんです それで我が子はそんなもん人にあげるもんでしょうかとかね
そんな態度も取る しかし
お寺に立派な家庭の子供をもらってはいるんですけどもね
どうせその子供の面倒を親に見られるし
でもまあ子供はそこで
まあもうそこで出家して思うならばありがたいんではないかと
でももう寺に上げたりもするしね
別にその親が子供のことを嫌ですかね
嫌じゃないでしょう でも乞食の場合は態度が違う
それで綺麗な何かあげたらどうしますか？と知ってます
売るんです 自分のお寺に来る
必ずしもご飯食べてからまずタオルを欲しいや
ベッドベッドスプレッドベッドシーツ
それ一つ あれ まあ本当にもう
まあいかないがね まあもう病気でも何かもう体にかけてあげたいんですよとかね
それで新しいものをあげても
ある場合はあげますけど
あれ持って使うと思いますかね
絶対使います 全部売って酒でも買ってね
どこ行ったんで人の仕事を奪うほど失礼なことはありません
だから乞食にお世話するっていうことは
逆に言えばその人の仕事を奪っちゃうんですよ
これ嫌がるんでしょう
我々でも同じことですよね
私の仕事を奪おうとしちゃうと
これほど嫌なことないでしょうに
仕事で食べてるんだから
苦労と不幸が乞食の大事な財産です
決して嫌なものではありません
不幸を楽しむ人には楽に生活することができるということなんです
だから乞食は楽に生きているんです
乞食してみれば 楽ですよ
着るものはないわ 体が病気はそれで障害を持っているとかね
それから見にくいとかね
まあ楽ですね すぐあのお金やらご飯やらもらえますからね
これは嫌味で言ってますけど
あとでわかりますからね
言ってるかと 心が萎縮する ５つの原因は限りない苦しみを作りますが
人が乞食の哲学を信じて
5つの重しを徹底的に守るのです
せっかく皆様に帰ってきたんですけどね
[笑い]乞食の哲学は誰がやっていますかといえば
人間みんなやってるんですよ
じゃあ乞食の話聞くと笑うでしょ
本当にバカらしいではないかと
笑い話になりませんよ
乞食の話も だって乞食に綺麗な服をね
洋服着かせて もうなんとかしてあげたいんで
どうやってそれから食べていけれますかね
じゃああんたに小さな家でも作ってあげるそうとかね
それからどうしますかね
だから笑い話じゃないんですよ
乞食は幸福をやれるのは笑い話じゃないんです
しかし問題ですよ それであの普通私たちには仏教の話になってくると
私たちの心がこの 5つの思いで
ものすごくさんざんもういじめられて
悪循環になってどうしようもない状態にいるんでしょうし
だったらやめればいいでしょ
しかし そう簡単じゃないんです
笑い話じゃないです これしか生き方がないんだから
自分をいじめることで生きているんだから
それやめちゃうとどうしますかと
例えば 五欲で生きているんでしょ
五欲以外楽しみがないと思ってるでしょ
五欲は抱いてください
何言うんでしょうか だから
この私はもうちょっとまあ独裁的に言いたがっているのは
普通の人々は乞食の哲学ですよ
乞食だよとは言わないんです
そうするとちょっと間違いですから
まあ乞食の哲学 思考パターンで生きている
それで乞食のことを知らなかったら
私の説明で理解してください
はい それからこのもうもう一つの方法で
この この重しの軽減ということで
この 5つの重いものがなぜ増えるか
なぜ減るかと チャートはまだ立派じゃないんですけど
まあ正確じゃないんだからね
例えば欲がありますね
欲がこの上 スバニミッターマニシカロティ
物事をこの好きなものばっかり考えたり
妄想したりすると わがまんまで好きなことばっかり考えたりすると
どんどんビーオーバーやウェープラーやさんになってくる
欲がどんどん増える 例えば
試しにちらっと目に入った美しい人のことを家に帰ってずっと考えてみてください
どうなるかと どんどん欲が増えてくるんですよ
そこで下 アスバニミッターマニシカロティ
物事の短所を考える どんなものでも長所を持ってるわけじゃない
だけ持ってるわけじゃないんですよ
短所も持ってます だからこれで一定で楽なんですけど
この今日プロジェクター持ってきたんだからね
私はだいたいこれぐらい講演の準備するために
まあ 5 分  7 分しか使えない
その時はデータはこれより 10倍揃うんです
全部喋りませんだけど
これには何日もかかったんですよ
まあまあ ちょっとちょっと時間かけてカード 1枚
2枚書いたり また時間かけてまあ 1枚
2枚書いて書いたり それでまあ朝までやって
朝の11時半までやって
だから何でしょうかと
それで持ってきたデータはっていうのはほんのちょっとなんです
私個人的にはまあ 1分ぐらいのデータなんです
... うん だから欲でいいんじゃないですかね
チャンではまああれだからね
言葉なりに 欲望とかね
ね 欲望っていう言葉もいいかもしれません
ん？その場合はまあ文字通り理解する
[笑い] 欲望ですね  まあまあ
まあ今思い浮かんだんですけど
はっきりした日本語の単語ないんですよ
例えば欲望や愛欲といえばまた違うんだから
これは欲が好きで好きでたまらんという意味なんですよ
だから私は依存症という言葉を使うんですよ
それで私も誰かさんに批判されましたけど
学問的じゃないんだと言ってる人は学問ってなんなかわからんとわかんなかった人だからね
まあもうしょうがないんですけど
でも怒ってはいますけどね
[笑い]で これはもう私はぴったし訳すると言えます
依存症っていうのはふざけた言葉ですが
意味はぴったしです だから欲依存症なんです
なぜかというと 美味しいものを食べたいっていうことは
そんなに仏教で否定しているわけは全くないんですよ
好きな音楽を聴くとかね
そんなのどうったことないんですよ
自分好きな色で壁紙を貼って
綺麗な部屋を作って インテリアを頼んで
何の問題もないんです
それは決して否定してないんです
それも欲の世界ですけど
否定していない 依存症なんです
否定 否定しているのは
だからもう半分当ててもなかなかいい感じが出てこないんですね
いい感じといういい意味が出てこない
まあとにかくそんなのはどうでもいいです
とにかく欲のことだから
でも 遊ぶにいった物事の短所を考えると
例えばあの人 本当にすごい美人なお姉ちゃんですけど
まあ美人も美人ですけど
でもまあ付き合おうとすればまたいろいろあるでしょうとかね
性格はどうでしょうかとかね
ただ綺麗なだけではもうナンパしてはいけないとかね
性格も考えなくちゃあかん
そういうふうに この それだけでも欲が減るでしょうに
若い男性が綺麗な女の人を見たところで
いきなりもう頭がおかしくなっちゃう欲で
それ依存症にならないで短所も考えてみる
綺麗だけではダメですと
もっともっとどうでしょうかと調べてみると
確実に短所が出てきます
面白いことは どんなものにも長所
短所があります それから人間
惹かれるものの場合は短所の方が多いです
長所の方が少ないんです
それは心の状態 惹かれるんだったら自然に決まって短所がたくさんになってる
長所がない ないではなくて少ない
まあ例出すのはよくわかることでね
嫌なことをした人に対して怒るのは簡単ですか？その人を助けてあげること簡単ですか
嫌なことした人に対して怒ること簡単でしょうに
それには心が惹かれるでしょう
でも 最初の嫌なことをした人に対して
また自分も嫌なことをすると結果どうなるんですかね
向こうは危険人物だから
自分に対してはさらに自分に迷惑をかける不利益を与えているだけでしょう
だからブッダがその人に親切にしてください
そうするとすごく嫌になるんですよ
何言うんですか あいつは悪い人間だとか思っちゃうんですね
だから自然に我々の心が行くものは
まあ長所が少なくて短所がありすぎ
そういうわけで 物事について短所を考えてみてください
観察するんです そうすると怒りがパヒー
欲がパヒー消えていく
そこで怒りの場合は パティダニミッターマニシカロというパティ
パティガニミッタっていうのは
っていうのは この自分がこの拒否する嫌なものっていうのをすぐ考える人
あれが嫌だ これが嫌だと考えちゃうんですよ
まあ私の思い浮かぶ例っていうのは
仏教は勉強したいんだけど
ゴータミ僧侶は嫌だと
というふうなことで パティガニミッタ
なんかあって嫌でしょうね
その人にとっては それだけ考える
仏教は勉強したいんですよ
したいのに パティガニミッタだけ考える
そうするとどんどん怒りが燃える
燃えてしまうんですよ
それで人間はそういう性格になりまして
この悪いところだけ考えちゃうと
自分に対して嫌なところだけ考えると
どんどん怒りがビーヨ
バーバーやウェープッラーヤさんがやってくる
それで下は怒りが消える方法
メッターチェートーウィモッティ
慈しみの思考で心を解放する
解放するとして 例えば自分に邪魔した悪いことした人に対して
まあまあ気にしない 私は助け
その人を助けてあげる
嫌な人だと思いませんよと
私はみんなと仲良くするんだぞと解放する気持ちになります
みんなと仲良くしてるんだから
なんで君と君と仲良くしますよ
君が私のことを嫌な君の勝手ですと
自由ですと どうぞ頑張ってください
しかし 私はもうみんなと仲良くするんだぞという解放感を味わうんですよ
それはメッターチェートーウィモッティという言葉なんです
専門家に聞くと またとんでもないわからない解説しますけど
字義辞書に基づいて禅定を作ることだというような解釈になりますが
私の解釈はこれです 解放感を味わってください
はい そうすると怒りが消えます
これ頑張ってください
大体みんなもう欲よりも怒りで苦しんでるでしょ
ですから いつでも慈しみを育てて
解放感 解放感を感じてください
小さくならないでください
心を みんな仲間だ もうもう私は仲良くするんだよ
私は狭くないんだよ 私の縄張りはかなり大きいんだよ
という感じでいてほしい
はい 次いきます それからあの
こっちに入ってますね
昏沈睡眠 こちらから直すか
で 昏沈睡眠状態 前説明しましたからね
それがこのアラティタンディーウィッジャンディターバッタサンマドーチェータソーリーナッタンということで
あんなこの嫌な怠けが出てくるんですよ
眠気やら怠けやらね アラティっていうのは退屈
これは辞書でなかったんですけど
私は入れたんです で タンディーは光宗さんの辞書で倦怠とありましたから
そのまま入れたんです
で 今は倦怠という でももう日本語で倦怠といえばまた別の意味となりますけどもね
それからウィジャンディターっていうのは
やっぱり退屈であくびが出る状態にいるという
なんとなく このちょっとドラマティックですけどね
パーリの言葉の で 次はバッタサンマド
あの辞書では食不調とあったんですけど
私は食後不調にしたんです
食不調といえば なんかどんな意味ですかね
あまり食が進まない  あ
そうでしょ だから間違いね
辞書にあったの食不調って意味なんです
私は食後不調と書いたんです
食後不調っていうのは
食べたらちょっとだるいでしょ
体が それなんです それから精神的体質
退屈する 体だけではなくて
頭も働かしたくないという退屈もあります
それはチェータソーリーナッタン
お釈迦様はいつでも体と心を分けて分けて分けて言うんですよ
それだったら どんどんどんどん昏沈睡眠が増えてしまう
で 下はなかなか難しいんですけど
アーランバダート アーランバダートっていうのは
まあこれは発音わからない感じですけど
あの  使わない感じですね
うん これが本当は作ったんです
で なかなか訳出んですよ
ダートという言葉がありますからね
アーランバっていうのは何かスタートする気持ち
始めようではないか 大体何でも始めたらうまくいくでしょ
みんなこの男の場合はね
食べて食べて この皿のものを放り込むでしょ
もう洗うのはもう嫌で
しかし 一旦始めれば もう皿も全部洗って
そこも全部掃除して 窓まで拭いて終わっちゃうんですよ
普段怠け者なのに だからこの始まる
あのエネルギーなんですよ
スタート 2番目はニッカマダート
ニッカマっていうのは
一旦始めたら進むということなんですね
一旦始めたんだから終わりまでやるぞ
今日食べる皿だけ洗うよ
洗おうと思って 汚い皿の中から一つ選んで洗って
やっぱり始めたから全部洗っちゃいますよということで
全部やってしまうということがニッカマダート
パラッカマダートっていうのは
そうやって終わるまでやるためには
もう持続するというか
持ち続けるエネルギーなんですね
努力する精神です それが簡単に育てますよ
モヤモヤ考える で 一応やりましょう
やりだす やり出したって終わりまでやるぞ
終わりまでやると思ったってば
途中でいろいろ嫌なことやらいろいろなのが起きますよ
でも全部もう気にしないで終わりまでやると
その ３つの現象です それやると
この根沈睡眠っていうのは消えてしまう
別にそれで このウッダッチクックッチは心の浮つきと後悔ですから
落ち着きないっていう状態ですからね
それはチェートスは奥様
まあ精神的には何でしたっけ？落ち着いてない
精神的な不安 育てちゃうとダメなんですよ
なんか不安になったと
不安になっちゃうと また次にまた不安になる
そうするとどんどん不安が増えていくんですよ
それでもウッダッチクックッチが
浮つきと後悔っていうのは
どんどん広げて広げて大きくなってしまって
もう潰されますね 重石で
重石だと思ってください
どんどんその石が重く重く重くなっていくんです
そこで逆にチェートスをウパサマ
穏やかな気持ちで不安を取り除く
精神的安定 落ち着く そうするともう後悔することもなく楽しくいられるんです
浮つきも消えてしまう
はい 次 ビチキッチャ ビチキッチャというのは疑惑
疑ですね 疑の場合はアヨーニソマニセカール
あの根拠に基づかないずがない思考
妄想 いわゆる感情でいい加減であれやこれやと考えると
どんどんものをわかるんじゃなくてわからなくなるんですよ
ですから ビチキッチャがどんどん増える
疑がどんどん増える だから妄想してはいけないということなんです
考えるんだったら 根拠に根拠があって
証拠があって それで考えて終わっちゃう
そういうことなんです
だからビチキッチャをなくすためには
ヨーニソマニセカール
論理的な思考 論理的に考えると
ビチキッチャ 疑っていうのは
あのすごい重石がなくなるんですね
いい加減で そうでもなる
そうかもしれないかもしれない
こうなるかもしれませんとかね
このかもしれません かもしれませんという思考パターンというのは
何にも結論に出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
すごい重石になってしまう
そんなもので 心が広くなったり
収縮したりする 収縮するのは上の方に行っちゃうと収縮する
下の方に行くと拡大する
はい で まあ読めばわかると思いますけど
心は心の曖昧な状態がない
確信があると曖昧じゃないでしょ
で 論理的に また証拠に基づいて物事を考えて理解する
世間...世間のことよりも自分の生き方に対してですね
間違い多い 具体的に理解して決める
ちょっと直しましょう
私は直しながらやりますけども
皆様を混乱しますからね
世間のですね  バカにしてます
ありますか 世間のことよりも
自分の生き方に対して具体的に理解して決める
だから信じる信じるで言っても
仏教の定義はこんな定義なんですよ
結構仕事なんですよ これ
そう簡単に信じるっていうことはできないんですよ
これ 私のいい加減な解釈じゃないんです
経典があらゆる経典の中でずっと調べていくと
こういう結論になるんです
いわゆるお釈迦様がよく言うサッダーっていうのは
サッダーパティッテ サッダーっていう信っていうのは出てできちゃうと
それでしっかりした生きる土台が立ち上がりますよ
それでしっかりと生きられますよ
ということは 宗教で言ってる信仰ではどうかなと
そうならないんですよ
それで説明はたくさんあります
で 下へ行きます ブッダの教えを理解すること
アーカーローティーサッカ
理性に基づく信 で はっきり言えばブッダの教えを理解することが信なんです
アインシュタインの教えを信じることは信になりません
まあ普通の知識だからね
心の論理ですからね 心で生きているんだから
心の科学を理解することが信になるんです
心の科学というのはブッダしか教えてないんです
そういうわけで ブッダの教えを理解することに信というんです
ブッダを信じることに信と言わないんです
私はブッダを信じていますよと言ったら
お釈迦様だったらあっち行けと
迷惑だと言うんです だからちゃんと理解する
ですから パーリ語でアーカーローティーサッキャ
アーカーローティーっていうのは
この論理的に成り立つ
ポシビリティーっていうのはすごい高い
事実であること 理性に基づく信
わからないが信じる ありがたいから信じる
信じれば信じればわかるなどは認めません
仏教は 信じればわかりますよというのは認めません
例えば宗教の世界で病気治すとかやってますね
それで治らなかった あんたの信仰足りませんよと
信じれば治りますよ そんなのは認めません
仏教は 仏教は逆 治すとなれば信じてあげる
あなたのハンドパワーで私の病気を治してくれたら信じてあげると
ということなんです その方が理性的なんです
それからえーと どこですか？認めないアモーリカーサッダーと言うんですよ
サッダーの反対 盲信 信仰なんですね
それから論理 理性 知識が働くと心が活発になるのです
やる気も出るのです これがスタートです
人間の本当にやる気っていうのは理性ですよ
理性が出てくるとやる気が出るんですよ
わかるとやる気でやりたいんですよ
何でもわかると自信になるとやりたいんですよ
だから このやる気が出た時にくだらんことするんじゃなくて
知識を発達するんですよ
理解するんですよ 理解するとやる気が出ます
例えば科学的なものでも
この法則なんとかよくわかっておけば
数学的に計算して あ こういうことだったらこういうことをやってみる
こういうことをやってみると
で 何でもできます だから
やる気のスタートはサッダー信という確信という
この論理的に理解していることなんです
これぐらいで早く終わりにしましょう
まだたくさんあるかな
これはずっと動くと思います
あの目覚めてもらわないと
それでそうやって作ったんです
私も暇があるもんですけどと思いますけど 2
番目は精進 精進というのはヴィリヤというんですね
怠けないで努力すること
心も体も動かすこと やってみる
えーと チャレンジ精神を持つ
なんかおびえるんじゃなくて
なんでもやってみるもんだよということで
なんでもやってみるんですよ
そうすると精進になります
しかし ただ頑張ればいいわけではありません
頑張ればいいというわけじゃない
何でもやってみればいいというわけでもないんです
心の悪をなくすために
善を完成するために努力するのです
これが仏教的な精進です
世俗的なことにも努力
努力すれば成功するに決まっているかもしれませんが
それでは人間として成長しないのです
物質的豊かさは精神的豊かさの億分の1にも値しない
良い人間になるために一生をかけるのです
それは決して精進しなさいと言ったら
では頑張るぞって何でも頑張ることをブッダは認めません
世俗世界でも頑張ればうまくいきますよ
うまくいく場合があります
頑張ってもうまくいかない場合もあります
それでうまくいって すごい物質的な豊かになったっても
あまり価値がないんですよ
精神的な豊かさが億分の1にならないです
だったら精神的豊かさにチャレンジするんですよ
かけてみるんです それに
命かけるならば 悪をなくすために
善を完成するためにかけるんですよ
命かけてやっても そんなに命死にはしません
なぜならば それは命のことだから
命を育てることだから
完全安全なやり方なんです
政治家の方々みたいに命かけて
それをやってほしくないんですよ
命かけて政治をなさってくれるは
あの不良債権なんか処理してくれるわ
もうありがたい話で やめた方がいいと思いますけど
だから命かけてやるんだったら
心軽やかにすることですよ
決して命はなくすことはないんです
はい 次 で あのサティということ
前もちょっと触れましたけど
これはものすごい機能なんです
これがこの唯一全部問題解決するためにある
この あの 何といいますか
この何かこの取っ手みたいなもんですよ
だからいろんな複雑なものをたくさん宝物があって
宝物はあらゆる方法で繋げている
取ろうといっても落ちたりもする
そうするとあれ一つあるんですよ
それで取っちゃうと全部繋がってくる
片っ端から全てそれがサティという機能なんですね
気づきということなんです
このヴィパッサナー瞑想でやらせているのはそれなんですね
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想のサティの実践すると
他のことに困らなくても全部ついてきます
だから 今 常に今の瞬間に気づいておく
実際しない過去にも現れてない
将来にも引っかからない
え？実在ですね そうそうそう
...えっと 実在しない過去にも引っかからない
この手法で心が妄想してエネルギーを浪費することを止めるなりやめるのです
あらゆる悩みも苦しみも
心の汚れが汚れ の妄想
ああ そうですね あらゆる苦しみ
心の汚れが妄想から発するものです
だから一切の汚れ 一切の煩悩っていうのは妄想ですよ
妄想から現れるんですよ
だからこれ一挙に一気にサティ
それからそれですごい具体的なんです
今の瞬間で生きてみる
ちょっと先の瞬間もうないんですから
実在しないんだから これから次の瞬間っていうのはまだ現れてないんだから
生まれてない子供にはもう別に結婚相手を探す必要ないでしょうに
まだ生まれて妊娠もしていないんだから
だからそれを余計なことを生まれたら考えればいいんです
結婚相手は二十歳ぐらいになってからなれば考えればいいんです
ということで 今の瞬間見るってことはものすごい強力なことなんです
で これが心を健康にする唯一の方法です
複雑に編み込まれて解けないと思っている心の糸は簡単に解くのです
心の問題っていうのはかなり複雑で
誰にも解説できないんですけど
これですべて解けていくんですよ
だから 編み物のようなもんですよ
あれ あるところがあるんですよ
ここから引っ張っちゃうと
どんな大きいセーターでももう簡単にもう解けちゃいます
解けてしまいますよ これがサティですよ
はい で サマーディ で 心の統一
集中力 まあで 知識も知恵も集中力がある人にのみ現れるものです
知識であろうが知恵であろうが
集中力ない人には全くないんですよ
集中力ない人は心ずっとガタガタガタガタ動いていることだから
何も残らないんですよ
ですから 集中なんか書けてますね
集中力を育てるためにいろいろ工夫があります
サマーディレベルまで成長させると心の威力がわかります
サティの実践で常に集中力を保つことができますというようなことで
サティ実践すると  24時間どんな仕事をしても集中力でいられます
あるいは特別に集中力を育てることもできます
いわゆるサマーディレベルというんですね
上のレベル 禅定のレベル
そちらになると自分でも驚くほど
これぐらい心の力があるかと
本当に力が見えてくるんです
今は我々はそんな力が感じませんだからね
体に抑えられてますからね
そんなことで集中力はどうしても必要ですよ
はい で パンニャン パンニャーは 2つです
カード えーと 集中力を観察することに回すと
集中力を観察することに回すと知恵が現れます
厳密に書いてましたけど
この集中力っていうのは必要ですけど
ものを見るために ただ見るだけで集中するだけでは意味がないんですよ
集中して観察するんですよ
集中力で観察する それがサティですけどね
前のカードはカードにあったものですよ
そこであの まあ例えば我々も映画を見ると集中して見ているわ
面白い本なんか読むと集中して読んでいるわ
それだけでは何もなりません
だから集中力で観察する
何かあるかというと そうすると知恵が出ます
で 理解能力の幅がどこまででも広くなってしまうことです
しかし 何でも知る必要はありません
迷惑でしょうしね 知ることで苦しみが増え
増やすものもあります
増すものもあります 何の役にも立たない知恵もあります
だから何でも知る必要ないんですよ
知った知ったからから困ったこともあるでしょうね
で 知ったってもどうったことないものもありますからね
選ばなくちゃいけない
仏教が認める知恵は 仏教の定義
苦しみを乗り越えるために
煩悩を断つために必要な知恵です
それだけの知恵で十分です
苦しみを乗り越える知恵
心の汚れをなくす知恵だけで十分です
サティを実践すると すべてのものは瞬間瞬間で変わること
消えていくことに気づきます
泡のように 蜃気楼のように
条件によって瞬間のみ現れて消えていく
取ることもできない 取られるものもない
また 現象は自分の意志でも他人の意志でも管理できないもので
できないものでもないというか
できないということです
ちょっと間違ってますね
管理できるものではない
ものでもない はい そこで心は執着から解放されるのです
こういう風に見てください
そうすると心が解放を味わうんですよ
で  2番目に行きます これは無常アニッチ
苦ドゥッカ 無我アナッタという普遍的な真理です
これが智慧というのです
この方向へ行ってほしい
それから因果法則 パティッチャサムパッという普遍的な法則の発見です
その 2つを発見する それで涅槃も体験できるし
悟れますし 苦しみは一切消えちゃうし
この 3つ無視してはできません
それがもう絶対的な真理になってきます
それから 本当の智慧はこの真理を発見することです
この智慧で心は執着から離れるのです
完全たる安らぎを体験するのです
そんな遠い話ではありません
無常であることはいつでも感じることだから
はい 次に行きます  これで終わりと思います
そこで  これをちょっとおしゃれに入れたんですけど
このある神霊が釈尊に尋ねる
これはある経典なんですね
カティジャーガラタンスッタカティスッテースジャーガラカティービラジェマデーティカティービパリスジェティ
起きていても寝ている状態がいくつ？質問するんです
寝ていても目覚めた覚めている状態がいくつあるのでしょうか？と
汚れが侵入する状態はいくつで
清らかになる状態はいくつでしょうか？と
答えられますかね そういう質問されちゃうと
ブッダ以外は答えられません
はい 釈尊が答えパンチジャーガラタンスッタパンチャスッテースジャーガラパンチェビラジェマデーティパンチェビパリスジェティ
起きていてもね 起きていても寝ている状態が 5つです
5つあります と 寝ていても覚めている状態が 5つですと
5つの条件で汚れが侵入する
5つの条件で清らかになる
だからコンパクトに喋るんですよ
漏れのもの何もなく で
これ解説あるかどうか分からない
次に行ってみて あ はい
それが 心に 5つの重しがある人は
たとえ物理的に起きていても
実は寝ているのです それなんです
重しのこと 重しがある限り
我々は頑張っているつもりですけど
汗だらして でも寝ているんです
妄想に陥って現実に目覚めていないのです
確信などの 5つを育れた人は
たとえ物理的に寝ていても目が覚めた人なのです
だから 後から入ったこのサッダ
信 確信と精進 気づき云々がありましたね
5つ それがあるともう寝ていたっても目覚めた人なんです
5つの重しがあること
ある時心が汚れるのです
5つの重石で心が汚れる
確信などの 5つがある時
心が清らかになるのです
これは解説 はい 次 自分を強調すると自分が優れると
これは別な なんですよ
これ 今までの話がわからないと複雑すぎるならば
これだけ覚えておいてください
あまり自分を強調しないこと
自分 自分 自分とか 私 私
私 私とか 生きてる上ではね
私ってこれ決して生きてみてください
すごい楽なんですよ 自我意識
自分を強調する 自分を気になる
これは心を萎縮させること
これは人の心を萎縮させるのです
それですよ 全くという
何か仕事する なんで私がと思うと
私が捨てろと 何か頼んだらやればいいし
時間がな時間ないんだって言えばいいし
それだけのことでしょう
人に何か嫌なこと言われて
嫌なことなりませんよ
[咳]私がという感じで聞くと
あ 嫌なこと言われてるんだとなるんですよ
私がというと消えちゃうと
あ この人なんか怒ってるみたいな
それで終わりますよ なんか怒ってるみたいなとかね
何だろうかとかね すごい楽なんですよ
どんな仕事もできる 自信がつく
見事にすべて解決する
能力はもうみるみるうちに増えていくんですよ
だから自我意識って強調すること
これはもう辞めることですよ
それだけで解決します
はい これで終わるかなと思いますけど
それを練習してみてください
また練習してください
今日はお釈迦様参ります
[笑い] はい それでは終わります
長い時間本当にありがとうございます